hello doctors right drew oh we were
gonna cancel yeah we we were we were
second away we were second away from
there you know I heard I heard the
direction you're gone I didn't like it
yeah we were about to go to war with
something even though he's been nice to
us for years we were like wait a minute
wait a minute dr. Drew's in there war it
was about to get very 1965 in here yes I
did I enjoyed that very much well thank
you when you visit Carolla sense but
didn't visit me come on now you know I
kind of wear thin on podcast so I don't
know people want me more than once I
want you more than once we were just
getting into our last time I talked to
you I enjoyed that very much
because I podcast is great but I mean
Adam just kind of like a segmented radio
show almost it's like Adam does a
gigantic three-hour monologue and you
sit and listen to it it was a
conversation I enjoyed yours very much
thank you I would do in a second I'm
glad I know dr. drew told me he thought
I was sexually abused it's been harping
in my I wonder if we do stories did you
tell him all right I just remember he's
been in my head for whatever they were
they were so manyy and so intense I had
to put it out of my mind yeah forget it
wait they really are damaging there's a
there's like this photo of Jim when he's
like a little kid and it's the most
adorable little kid you've ever seen
right he's probably like what's our six
by what happened pull it up dude oh my
god so painful to think about it and
he's got this little bandaid on his head
and it's like you want to believe like
oh he's probably playing with his trucks
uh-huh and like he fell and hit his head
and he goes oh no I wasn't molested
because I was not molested but that that
little nick that I got on my head that
was because I was running away from the
bully that used to make me perform
fellatio on and I'm like at that age and
that's not sexual abuse calling look at
that photo
I mean just the the--in in the game
they're just like heartbreaking and then
it is horrible yes what's even worse
though is the [ __ ] wallpaper in the
back ninety seventy [ __ ] all my and your
classless parents that is a classic 1973
yeah Edison New Jersey yeah perfect
there was any question as to whether Jim
Norton was Jersey trash right dishes
away my god right on top of the fridge
we were garbage not that long ago were
you were like a Forte playing a press
from the audience asking questions and
they showed the outtakes after was the
love that series or something like that
and you were just going off sexually
they let you just go and they didn't put
any of it in the story but they put it
in the outtakes later I don't know and I
was like wow Jim's worse than I thought
is that amazing he doesn't remember that
was just like that's a day in the life I
don't like the thing that you were like
oh my god this is that Amy Schumer joke
yes reporter yeah have you heard because
it you don't mind if I brought stuff you
brought up on the air have you heard
about this penis therapy that people
send audio shockwaves a gateway into the
penis to try to heal it yes is this a
real thing it's a real thing I'm not
sure how effective it is you know I have
a prostate cancer and so I had a
prostatectomy and so I was the young man
is like no idea yeah and I had that five
years ago and in so there was a
possibility that I could have those
kinds of problems so I'm sort of paying
attention to all that stuff everything
turned out fine I have no issues or did
you have to pump they say if you don't
know I have a pump I use my put my penis
pump broke would you break your penis I
don't know but the charge won't take
anymore using it too
bottom line yourself but up so you use
your cuz you were using your penis pump
like regularly but not like a large but
two notes to make it the blood flowing
yeah I'm going back to sways it doesn't
have micro damage and all of a sudden
it's supposed to you know the new blood
vessel you understand what works but it
actually it has been effective it
doesn't give you any size it just makes
you a little harder well the pump that
to really have effect is supposed to be
a ring that get snaps around the base
yeah there is yeah so you you have to
snap the outflow and increase the inflow
and that makes your harder
yeah just kind of stays there and they
do that after you like the gains waves
treatments they do you feel a difference
there they are effective yeah yeah all
this stuff is effective and then of it's
a hundred percent effective or you could
you know effective entirely or they're
not everyone's satisfied all the time or
anything but but for the most part if
somebody has problems like this you can
expect to have good outcomes like like
yield they'll figure something out it's
an unguent it's it's like it's
cumulative a few different things you do
you take that you take a sigh Alice yeah
tweedle in your nipples Holthus can I
ask you about the humping yeah my if I
ask about the humping you can ask him
okay your opinion because I've been
obsessed about humping the humping I've
been obsessed with the humping some bad
M night Shyamalan the humping it's
coming so Jim had spent several years of
his life as a frequent in constant
masturbator and shock in yes in an in
his effort of a penis health which goes
along with the shock waves in the penis
pump he wanted to be able to have like
to use his penis more healthily
you know and to be able to maintain an
erection your magic wand wanted to
maintain an erection and to be able to
climax without like a whole bunch of
[ __ ] without a bunch of bells and
whistles you my dick is a [ __ ] a
dopamine
lever that's masturbation addictions
right that's Jim yeah yeah but so what
are you talking about this in the
podcast well I remember when sort of the
stuff we were talking about with Jim but
I but this is much more efficient
hearing all the dirt we're a
straight-out productor expecting it from
you but go ahead so what Jim did was
instead of he said I'm not gonna
masturbate anymore okay because that's
the issue
that I just do it over and over again
about yeah there's no sensitivity right
that's good so what he did was he bought
a sex doll but just the pelvis part like
a severed pair with some buddies
it was some porn stars no my flesh light
was but I have my flesh like kept caving
in and I kept I kept bumping my pubis on
the plastic I got so mad when I took
with my [ __ ] girlfriend I broke out
my fluoride getting concerned okay so
what he does is he's been having he's
been trying to have sex with sex would
you know not full-on sex of Elvis no
this sex dolls because he says latex
pelvis right yeah if he learns to [ __ ]
the sex doll oh I see and humping yeah
you know without touching right playing
my nipples are doing awesome then he can
start having minute early desensitized
show up and made himself dependent on
what the masturbatory experience is yeah
as Adam Carolla says sex is good it's
just not the real thing yeah that
happens a lot to people so you think
that's a real thing which is doing well
it's an interesting solution he's trying
to adapt here but the the what he's
experiencing is a common thing my purse
told me it was actually a good that's
really rich well the fact that he
stopped wanted to stop masturbating
that's a good thing but I'm the problem
is now he's with his pelvis how often
not very often I haven't in weeks
okay good so that's what he'll do is
he'll get on the bed and he'll kneel
next to the pelvis now sets laptop up
I've done Adam show maybe that's a
martyr on their marker to see it but
yeah because you look so familiar but
but what we're what ultimately is under
this is not the funny part anymore but
what's ultimately underlying stuff the
gyms talking about is an intimacy
problem
intimacy disorders so it's interesting
that rather than going hey I should stop
the mass rain and develop a relationship
with human being he goes to a latex
pelvis
it's still kind of the same problem as
prepared so you're saying that it's it's
it's an emotional thing it's an intimacy
thing usually it which means that the
solution is not going to be found in the
penis or the pelvis or the pelvis or the
latex but but you'll admit this that
there's usually a longing for a real
relationship sure yeah seeing this and
that's and that longing oftentimes the
people that have lots of relationships
and yet they don't know how to a real
relationship are they that long
continuous in the same boat there yeah
well you're in a relationship though
you're doing well but you've been in a
it's hard so unlike you I had a question
for you that's totally non-sexual ated
how did you end Stanhope makeup could
you and you wrote the foreword to Doug's
book yeah so that's a great that's right
thank you for asking them yeah I love
Doug and I love yeah he's the best and
he I really was you know me I'm out of
it I don't know what's going on having
the time in terms of culture and guy
stuff I just sort of sure plod through
and you know I get to meet everybody and
so that's how I get exposed to stuff and
I heard that Doug was just railing on me
on his stand-up like really railing arms
about smoking weed right he was just
ranting on about he's very anti 12-step
because his mom used to drag him to
12-step meetings and stuff he and Jim
actually at one point got into a huge
argument on the air yeah what do you say
was that much of an argument well stuff
it was yeah it was like you know I know
he's God is about what he said was an
argument it was a disagreement about it
it was a disagreement celebrates his
humaneness and I love that about him
right and if he gets into trouble he'll
deal with it one day and I and he
thought I was the like don't do drug
police or though I'm gonna judge you
police or something and I'm the farthest
thing from that I love people like Doug
I worry about him I care about him this
thing tends to progress you know and he
could get into trouble and I hope we can
help him if he needs it someday in the
meantime I glory and who talks down
office you know he's a great guy and a
great comedian and doing crazy and
dangerous stuff but okay that's that's
his life and he came on my podcast armed
like to kill he wanted like he'd like
came in just to destroy me did you know
like you're late I know that really and
and I was like that's not I was sort of
confused I might Doug it's you got the
wrong idea and we made
on the podcast sorry when you booked him
on the podcast did you know that there
are no railing on me so I was expecting
trouble but I didn't know he came to
kill rhyme to really destroy me and and
I'm Who I am and he's honest enough to
like accept that and we became friends
that's interesting though that you were
like I hear this guy's talking all this
[ __ ] let's book him on the podcast let's
figure out what that's how it should be
face to face it sounds better and that's
again that's hit to his that's more of
it hats off to him than to me because he
knew how he was feeling and how bad it
was of what he wanted to do I was sort
of kind of clueless but like out let's
look at let's talk about let's get into
this because it cuz I what I was hearing
was so far from Who I am
yeah that I thought wow this is there's
something going on the Rogen does the
same thing yes it's like dude that is
not who I am yeah I think he has the
same misconception he does at Roseanne
on yeah I keep saying that oh we're
friends come back in there I think clay
you and Joe had a thing
he keeps railing on me too lately and he
I think he thinks I'm I don't know he's
sort of an tied treatment for addiction
he thinks I'm anti pod or something and
and I which I'm not
and it's like I'm doctor I'm just trying
to help people it's it yeah we very
simple do you did you ever go through a
point where you were like cuz you you've
been in the media spotlight for a long
time but I think that stuff really
started to hit when Celebrity Rehab
became such a big show that's when
people really started to yeah do you
ever get to places where you're like I
don't I don't want to do this in public
anymore I just want to help people I'm
gonna go into this quiet room where
nobody's looking it's just people but
but I like I our culture is sick right
so I like the fact I'm grateful they had
a chance to try to change things on a
larger scale I enjoy that but day in day
out I'm helping people 101 so I do but
if you ever wanted to just give up the
medias oh oh uh you know I my daughter
and I were talking about this last night
she was what are you gonna retire and I
go I feel like the things are such a
mess in this country right now I feel
like I have unfinished business it's the
weirdest feeling I would like to retire
but but I I feel like I sort of feel
like you know I'm a quarterback on the
5-yard line and I got to get something
into the end zone I don't even know what
that means and it's a feeling and so the
answer is I'll keep doing it until you
know it means you just saw The Longest
Yard
[Laughter]
it's weird that I can't tell you what
that means it's right it's a feeling on
what level is it because people are
doing pills like crazy is it because I
always go and control the outrage and
the hate and the extremism the tribalism
the narcissism all this stuff it's like
it needs to get solved and I want to be
a part of the solute I'm gonna help
solve it it's like there's too much for
me to go I'm out I'm tapping out I had
too much that I feel like I could do so
chillin whelming - there's so much of it
and there's so much coming from so many
areas it's overwhelming - let's see just
you know how can you sit back and not do
do anything you enjoy doing it I enjoy
doing I'm grateful and I have this huge
opportunity and it's like a weird
synthesis of stuff I know how to do and
my talents and my skill and my training
and it's like geez I I would feel so
irresponsible also I'm just tapping out
ready just sit on it right I I don't
know if I could sit on the sidelines it
was a game going on and it's like it's
it's it you need the team needs your
help
so you do when you watch like when you
look at all the outrage going on on a
psychological level you want to help
people with that - well mmm
it's not that simple I look at the
outrage and I go okay where I know the
history and I know what's going on a
media and I had a cable TV show on and
see how they would they that was so
duplicitous and all this but what I see
is what I call the narcissistic turn and
people don't really understand this is
that our personality styles in this
country have shifted oh yeah when I was
first working in a psychiatric hospital
in the early 80s we have a part of the
form when people are admitted you know
with their their personality diagnosis
and you would see all kinds of
personality of diagnoses in there and
it's come about mid-1990 all
narcissistic disorders 100% 100% and
that was a shift and that shift is now
being reflected in all our you know yes
no digital black-white thinking in all
our outrage in all our personalization
of everything but that's the hard human
sacrifice behavior I mean all that mob
action on social media French Revolution
exactly and I and I wanted to put a
chapter in my narcissism book from the
from 10 years ago about
pre-revolutionary France because I could
see this coming
yes I saw it coming now people want me
to write a book about this whole thing
yeah we're here explaining do you think
social medias ought to do it like that
everybody's being heard
their opinions and technology they get
angry and they think their opinion means
more than one person okay it's an echo
chamber and yes it's gratifying in that
way Jim and also it's a public square
and guess what went down on the pounds
wears back in your you must be a history
buff because in the public squares
that's why Europeans started subdividing
their public squares making them smaller
spaces as you give humans a place to
congregate bad stuff Doug Lee yeah yeah
yeah i sooo knew we were going here from
jim's palace my pelvis is usually the
jumping-off place for all discussions on
this program what do you think started
this in the 90s because usually like
this it seems almost like you know like
social media and that culture is a
symptom of what was already starting
Iraq yeah
pair exactly right it's the trauma we
went in the 60s 70s and to some extent
80's we went through you experience a
gym in epidemic of childhood trauma and
adverse childhood experiences epidemic
and we're not really dealing with that
yet we're not really talking about it
and in the context we should the 60s we
just unraveled and kids were just sort
of cast out and families were destroyed
and kids were exploited and hurt and
traumatized like crazy like like like
never before
however if you go look at
pre-revolutionary France same [ __ ] was
going on uh-huh do you think where do
you think we're gonna have a French
Revolution here well how do we're in it
when you teen is the public square which
is Twitter right that's the gay as a pro
yeah and much like that look the
Russians when they would dispatched
people they didn't very often send
people to Siberia or kill people they
fired them that was the end of you're
effectively the most powerful thing you
could do that sort of ended their life
specially in that system take away their
job we're doing that now yeah the ones
got to be fired it was gonna be fired
yes so they did do what your name and
Lane is right they fired her she had to
become a prostitute right eats out her
hair if the dreamer ations and
businesses had any ethical backbone how
the first move would be first thing
we're not gonna do is fire we'll look
into this we're not gonna fire them will
discipline them but do all kinds of
things find them whatever no firing they
fire you for saying yeah you know the
reason of saying thing not not even that
egregious just saying something of any
sanity this thing we're into what
everyone has to be fired for
what been telling a stoic says yes the
excessive story about a helicopter being
shot at you got to be fired but you're
right because they get fired and then
they do get cast away in the sense that
like the mob just wants to know they got
fired and punished and then nobody ever
thinks about them again examples up
nobody is a new thing come they're done
let me move on to this what I think they
did with the guillotines yeah next cuz
no one feels like they're being heard
everyone feels like we have no impact so
if you're a part of something that gets
somebody fired or gets a result you're
like oh [ __ ] I have some kind of an
impact my hero yeah that's a grandiose
narcissism yeah and it's and that's
what's underlying all that and that the
so behavior of crowds in the setting of
predominant narcissism very dangerous so
how do we flip it what's the solution
awareness first and then not you know
he's trying to try to make a case
against firing everybody that has a
misstep and raising a healthy you know
working on our families and educating
people properly and working on a
healthier system there because I guess
it's one of those things that has to
happen generationally yeah we can we can
dampen our narcissism right now we're
we're amplifying it right dampen it down
all not on her system is bad I don't
consider a pejorative it's just a style
and it's a style that has a liability
well it gets bad because because
underneath it can be feelings don't
matter and therefore your feelings don't
matter right and you don't matter right
it's a man gratify me yes we're
promoting I know you need something with
Chris Christie you're doing a no just
got my website that's the main thing
oh yeah okay everything's there let's
just do it there I've done the podcast
as you know and that I'm interested in
promoting that stuff and and I put I
published a multi-part series on the
opiate crisis and I'm gonna put that out
as an audio book and you'll see the
narcissism stuff up there soon yeah make
it competitive about being the doctor
that has the most attention on you in
the sense that since you started this
thing like you're one of the early ones
and when love language first starting
there weren't a lot of doctors out there
but there are a lot more doctors now dr.
Steve great communicators right know
that are like okay I'm gonna be doing
this stuff to do you have that kind of
Hollywood competitiveness in you know
but I but I I have a problem with people
that make claims to professional
standards that DV let's put this way if
somebody says I'm dr. so-and-so and you
look on their website then they don't
have their credentials there they are
not a doctor and who knows what their
training is they're people that have the
training or she put it out there they
want you to know about it yeah people
that have just you know some sort of
educator training or something it's like
give me a break
I think about I think lots of them there
are lots of that fits a lot of people
learn with the medical school I did a
residency I did a postgraduate I have
two board certifications it's on my
website you'll find it there easily
that's true people who do that kind of
work to get that kind of stuff they
would like everybody to know for the
graduates please ask me those questions
yeah the other ones they go so and so is
a world-famous educator and it had been
on lots of podcast with Jim Norton and
Sam Robertson that's like it's like no
your training and more importantly who
the [ __ ] are those guys